[Applauso]
queste sono foto che erano in casa mia
ho cambiato casa quindi non ci sono più
queste foto la prima volta che quello
che poi sarebbe diventato il mio
compagno per un poco è entrato a casa
per una cena abbracciandomi vide molte
di queste foto e probabilmente è toccata
da un attimo di perplessità e di sé
quante foto di donne che in questa casa
io colsi la cosa così ridendo perché
comunque non mi stupiva però non me
n'ero mai veramente accorta l'avevo
collezionate da tempo le tenevo la e mi
piacevano e le le donne sono sempre
stato un un esempio sempre cercato
esempi perché perché malgrado io sia
biologicamente una donna non penso o
comunque non è stato così semplice per
me capire le tante sfaccettature
dell'essere dell'essere donna appunto
l'esempio viene dal viene dal latino
trarre fuori lo conosciamo come appunto
il trarre fuori dalla dalla massa una
persona si si mette in evidenza perché
esemplare per all esempio a me fa
l'effetto assolutamente simile a me fa
tirar fuori quelle che sono degli
aspetti miei che magari non conoscevo
così ecco quel password che avete visto
prima probabilmente sono alcune delle
mie tante parti
proprio per questa mia come dire
dedizione ad esempio innamoramento
dell'esempio bisogno delle esempio ho
pensato di innanzitutto che se serviva a
me probabilmente sarebbe servito anche a
tante altre donne
e così l'ho fatto diventare il mio
mestiere
io amo definirmi come una raccoglitrice
di storie esemplari di donne
raccoglitrice e allo stesso tempo
dispensa tri cel e raccolgo e poi li
ridò perché beh perché per due motivi 1
personalissimo sono una donna quindi ho
bisogno di esempi
2 perché la trasformazione che se vi
racconterò oggi fa parlare fa dire a
qualcuno che il xxi secolo sarà la e il
secolo in cui le donne interverranno nel
mondo per cambiare la la realtà
a vent'anni mi stavo per la avevo tutto
sembrava mi sto per laureare un
fidanzato bellissimo andavo tutte le
domeniche a pranzo dai suoceri e avevo
una casa che ci aspettava eppure
quell'agosto tornata dalle vacanze
dovevamo già un po che ti abbiamo
parlato addirittura di matrimonio
sento all'università la voce di di fabio
fabio mi aveva così fatto un po la corte
durante l'anno precedente ma io
fedelissima avevo sempre rifiutato
quindi in quel momento ho sentito il mio
cuore bum bum bum bum bum battere in
quell'istante in un istante ho deciso
uno a 21 anni non posso rinunciare a
questo cuore che batte in questo modo 2
accetto l'invito di fabio e lascio il
mio fidanzato mi sono girata e sono
andata verso di lui
potete immaginare quell'evento non è lui
fabiano è diventato il mio fidanzato
siamo usciti una volta e così è andata
ma io ho continuato a credere che fosse
stato lui a farmi battere il cuore
quindi cambiato lui ho fatto come tutte
le ventenni o semplicemente continuato a
cambiare fidanzati la quello che questa
immagine racconta in maniera racconta un
evidenza la donna è felice e se stessa e
alla sua massima potenzialità del cuore
quando è madre questa si chiama alle tre
età della donna quindi insomma è
abbastanza chiaro come una non lascia
alternative di interpretazione e l'altra
la totale il totale appagamento
questo è un concetto che nella cultura
italiana non possiamo ridimensionare è
difficile contestare che anche
nell'immaginario il cuore della donna
batte nella sua massima potenza quando è
madre
leggendo i tanti uno di un bellissimo
libro tra l'altro la storia del mondo
dal punto di vista delle donne sono
capitata in quella che è definita la
teoria del destrimano la faccio breve le
do nell'era a primitiva le primedonne
tenevano con il braccio sinistro i loro
bambini perché il cuore battendo li
rassicurava così che loro potessero con
la destra fare cose
quello che è successo è che da quel
momento in poi il mondo è diventato
destrimano c'è un mancino su dieci
persone che utilizzano destra con tutto
quello che significa l'impatto che
questa cosa ha significato su tutti su
tutti i fronti
allora mi sono chiesta in quanti altri
modi le donne usano il cuore per dare
forma al mondo sedici anni dopo quel
fabio quattro anni fa per la precisione
io mi sono ritrovata con il cuore che
ancora una volta batteva poco ero un
autrice televisiva però non ero una
delle migliori attrici e pagata tanto
quanto le grandi autrici televisive
aveva una casa che era difficile da
mantenere
e i tanti uomini con cui usciva non
erano mai quelli giusti insomma
sostanzialmente quello che era stato
tutta la mia progettualità per creare la
mia felicità si era dimostrata un
fallimento a quel punto o oltre a vedere
tantissimi ted che mi hanno veramente
supportato in maniera
sostanziosa e sostanziale
ho deciso ho pensato cos'è che fa
veramente battere il mio cuore io devo
far battere il mio cuore in una maniera
incontestabile per sempre
a questo punto mi sono mi sono mi sono
ricordata di questo post it che stava lì
da veramente tanto tempo per la mia casa
ma che io vedevo facevo finta di non
vedere quello che ti piace fare e ciò
che sai fare meglio cos'è che mi piaceva
veramente fare a me piacciono le parole
a me piace la la scrittura
ho tentato come una protagonista di un
film hollywoodiano di fare della
scrittura
il mio mestiere ho scritto per un anno
subaffittato casa ho scritto un romanzo
che tu un film scritto serie tv
rappresentate niente ovviamente non è
successo niente
io mi ero trovato la situazione
cominciava ad essere veramente
pericolosa
e allora ho fatto ok devo tornare alla
mia vecchia soluzione
gli esempi ho bisogno di esempi come
hanno fatto le altre come l'ho fatta a
trasformare la loro passione in un
lavoro ce ne sono altri sono matta
solamente io oppure ce ne sono tante
altre
la così sta di fatto che ho cominciato a
scrivere a intercettare queste storie la
vita ti viene incontro quando oggi
viverla veramente così ho avuto
l'occasione da allora ancora oggi di
collaborare con un grande giornale
italiana per il quale scrivo storie di
donne imprenditrici ne scrivevo più mi
dicevo macabro ma quante sono queste ma
quante ne trovo bellissimi potenti
originali ma quante ne sono mi sono
dedicata proprio a dei numeri perché per
stare con i piedi per terra ha deciso
che avevo bisogno di numeri e questi
numeri erano mi hanno portato a questa
scoperta in italia oggi allora erano di
più ma in italia oggi ci sono un milione
e quattrocentomila donne che fanno
impresa solamente nel 2005 cioè l'altro
ieri praticamente è stato redatto il
primo rapporto sull'imprenditoria
femminile io non sono una tecnica su una
scrittrice
però questo è significativo le
come dire non esisteva prima il caso è
al di là delle tante caratteristiche
perché le donne fanno impresa in tutti i
settori in cui fanno tradizionalmente
impresa gli altri c'è un settore altro
in cui sono tantissime tant'è che non
solo hanno deciso appunto chi fa queste
valutazioni di aggiornare i questionari
perché i questionari non raccontano le
imprese al femminile sfugge tra le
maglie ma sono tutti concordi
nell'immaginare nel sostenere che
quell'altro è cura le donne si occupano
di cura però non facciamo l'errore
banale di considerare la cura appunto la
badante o baby sitter o l'infermiera
cura ancora una volta viene dal latino
cura è cuore le donne partendo dal punto
di vista del cuore intercettano bisogni
personali innanzitutto e poi trovando
nella soluzione ne fanno dei servizi o
degli oggetti che servono a tanti altri
vi potrei raccontare la storia di di
daniela che sarda che in sardegna per
l'appunto la tanta lana sarda che
normalmente non viene utilizzata per la
tessitura e viene regolarmente bruciata
spendendo soldi spendendo energia
inquinando beh lei ha pensato che quella
lana potesse essere utilizzata e adesso
lei la sua azienda produce pannelli
isolanti sia sonori che per le
temperature migliori d'europa
e alla domanda perché sono così perfetti
i tuoi perché li faccio io
oppure vi potrei raccontare la storia di
sarah giovanissima stilista americana
che è venuta in italia perché è più
bello stare in italia e che volendo
trovare un'idea di moda utile all'uomo
ha messo a punto insieme un'azienda
italiana un tessuto di cotone e argento
che ha il potere di repellere la zanzara
la zanzara e la portatrice del virus
musica che regolarmente
insomma fa ammalare i feti delle donne
in gravidanza
lei ha appreso dal suo punto di vista
del cuore ha preso sulle sue spalle
l'idea di fare qualcosa per questa cosa
mentre faceva il suo mestiere ovvero la
stilista e così ha tirato fuori la prima
linea premaman che ha questa possibilità
ovvero di difendere le donne in
gravidanza perché sapete che in alcuni
paesi è addirittura vietato abortire
quindi insomma diventa complicato poi
essere costrette a tenere quella quel
quel feto malato oppure ancora vi posso
raccontare la storia di viva una
scienziata italiana che ha messo a punto
un elemento di robotica che ha la
capacità di rimbalzare la luce del sole
sempre in uno spazio predefinita
attraverso dei dei codici e qual è il
punto di cuore e di vista con cui diva
ha pensato e creato questo che sto
questo elemento è quello di portare la
luce dove c'è il buio portare la luce
dove sia tecnicamente non è possibile
avere l'energia elettrica oppure dove
c'è troppa luce artificiale
ecco io potrei ancora raccontarvi la
storia di silvia paganica a milano ha
creato la prima scuola del mondo non
scuola dove gli alunni non studiano
materie ma utilizzano il fare la
fotografia la chimica e tante altre cose
tali da imparare ad essere prima che
imparare la teoria ce ne sono centinaia
io non raccontato centinaia sia per il
giornale che per il sul mio sul sito che
ho che ho creato per per raccontare
questi esempi perché gli esempi sono
fondamentali per sapere che si può fare
il mondo il mondo nel quale abitiamo ha
chiaramente bisogno di cura ma una cura
ecologica una cura economica una cura
culturale una cura spirituale il punto
di vista della cura quindi il punto di
vista del cuore è quello che le
imprenditrici
stanno portando nel mondo con le loro
azioni la cosa interessante è come
proprio partendo da una necessità
privatissima io devo fare questa cosa
perché è importante per me allora faccio
qualche cosa che probabilmente molto
probabilmente è importante per tanti
altri
in questo modo si creano imprese sensate
l'impresa è un'impresa quando i
cavalieri del medioevo partivano per
l'impresa avevano un vessillo è un'idea
da difendere da sostenere dal riportare
a casa
ecco l'impresa vuol dire fare con
dedizione una cosa le donne devono
portare il mondo lucia iraci è
un'imprenditrice italiana che a parigi
ha realizzato qualche cosa che finisce
regolarmente nelle rubriche di economia
dei giornali francesi
lei sa che è una parrucchiera una delle
migliori per una più costose
parrucchiere italiane che alla francesi
che al lato ha creato un'altra piccola
associazione che ancora una volta fa i
capelli alle donne che hanno perso tutto
perché il principio di quella sua
associazione è quella di ri curare la
bellezza estetica in modo tale che le
persone oggetti di questo di queste cure
possano curare la loro bellezza
interiore perché dice noi possiamo
curare l'esterno tutti devi concentrare
completamente sulla bellezza di te come
essere umano è interessante questo
perchè non solo sa ne ha create tre sedi
in tutta la francia ha creato anche una
scuola con il criterio di educare alla
cura
ecco lei dice che le donne devono
portare il mondo perché il mondo in
questo momento a
[Musica]
urgente bisogno di cure cura viene da
cuore dal latino ma anche coraggio viene
da cuore la questione della cura ha
profondamente a che vedere con quello
che è il passaggio che le donne in
questo momento stanno vivendo è come se
stesse accadendo una trasformazione
antropologica
quello che è accaduto in italia milione
e quattrocentomila donne che fanno
impresa immaginate sta accadendo su
tutto il mondo e allora come è possibile
che nello stesso momento in tutto il
mondo stanno facendo questa cosa quello
che accade è che le donne stanno uscendo
da un immaginario che raccontava la loro
felicità o che suggeriva a loro un certo
tipo di fili felicità per spingerle a
cercare una felicità che è vero c'è
quella che sta dentro il loro cuore che
è sostanzialmente la cosa che sono
venuti a fare al mondo le imprenditrici
non sono io non parlo di imprenditrici
perché solo perché sono donna ma perché
è proprio una questione numerica
immaginate un mondo siamo concordi tutti
che il mondo in cui abitiamo è un mondo
creato diciamo che lo hanno creato prima
gli uomini ok hanno parlato prima hanno
detto prima in un mondo che il rischia
di sciogliersi gli acciai di il petrolio
finisce ma finiscono i modelli culturali
stanno finendo i modelli economici
noi abbiamo un bacino di possibilità che
è l'altra metà del mondo
l'altra metà del mondo che sta
intervenendo e sta iniziando a dire io
penso questo io faccio questo e
facendolo lo stanno dimostrando
un'altra caratteristica ci sono due dati
che mi va di condividere con voi prima
di terminare le imprese al femminile
sono piccoli di media perché hanno
appunto una media di 5 addetti perché
nel piccolo che è sicura che sicura ci
si cura di tutti i dettagli e quindi ai
tanti
se mi dicono sì vabbè ma non fanno
fatturato abbastanza io dico basta
semplicemente farne di più saranno tutti
contenti
il fatturato sarà lo stesso e ancora
l'ultimo dato l'età media delle donne
che fanno impresa e pre 35 50 anni
questo vuol dire che prima hanno provato
tutte ad incarnare un altro immaginario
di felicità che non significa che non
sia vero ma non è più il solo e unico è
possibile
l'ultima slide il pianeta terra cura se
stesso attraverso il lavoro delle donne
immaginate se fosse così a me piace
pensare così questa cavalcata di donne
che stanno arrivando per curare loro
stesse facendolo cureranno il mondo
[Applauso]